[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme il serait doux peêtreop près de
vous dans ces moments où vous refermez
la porte derrière
vous pour me cacherz
tout le meilleur de
vous toutes vos manies c'est coins
secret qui me sont
interdits derrière le verrou j'attends
et je Bou dans ces moments longs ou
courts c'est celon que faites-vous don
j'entends des bruits
mou qui me rendent fou des bruits de
coton des bruits de chiffon des bruits
de
flacon vous
parfumezv ou bien
buvez-vous quelques vin bizarre que vous
cacheriez au fond d'un
placard quel beau rendez-vous que vous
avec vous je n'entends plus rien
êtes-vous en train d'admirer vos
seins les caréz
vous dessus et
dessous ma folle pensée vient s'imaginer
leur pointe dressée
dans un garde à vousou si dur et si doux
madame
ouvrez-moi ne me laissez pas dans cet
état là j'entends tout à coup frémir le
verrou vous apparaissez vous me regardez
d'un air étonné parz de bijoux lourd de
frou et soudain j'ai peur comme si je
vous croisais dans un
ascenseur je jette sur vous des yeux de
Hiou sans un mouvement comme sous
lesffet d'un
[Musique]
envoutement avec une mou frisant le
dégoût pour me balancer j'ai mal à la
tête prépare un
caché et un
point c'est
tout